[موسيقى]
اسمها فيكتوريا اميلينا كاتبه وباحثه في
جرائم الحرب تاريخ الوفاه الاول من يوليو
الجاري في قصف روسي على مقهى بكراماتورسك
شرق اوكرانيا التشييع والوداع الاخير كان
في كييف عاصمه بلد في حرب يزيد ضحاياها كل
يوم وايضا تدفق الاسلحه وتقل فيه فرص سلام
ينهي هذا الصراع المدمر للجميع كان الزمن
هنا لتعداد الهجمات المتبادله والقتل
والجرحى من الطرفين استنادا الى الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه قتل ما لا يقل عن 31 شخصا في
قصر على خركيز شمال شرق البلاد في تفاصيل
البيان ذكر ان الضربه استهدفت موقفا
للسيارات خارج مبنى من ثمانيه طوابق شهدت
خرسون ايضا قصفا اودى بحياه مدنيين
باعتراف طرفي الحرب الاشتباكات مستمره في
اغلب الجبهات المشتعله في غياب مصدر مستقل
يؤكد او ينفي روايتك قال امين عام مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني اوليكس ان الهجوم
المضاد الذي بدا قبل شهر كان مثمرا بشكل
خاص في الايام القليله الماضيه تقييم لا
تعترف به روسيا التي اعلنت احباط مواصفاته
بالعمل الارهابي داخل اراضيها التصوير كان
عن بعد وفق الصيغه الرسميه لبيان وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه خمس
مسيرات اربعه في ضواحي موسكو وواحده في
المدينه دون وقوع اصابات او اضرار ماديه
باشد العبارات دانه المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه ماريا زخرفه ما حدث وكتبت عبر
تيليجرام ان محاوله نظام كييف استهداف
منطقه تقع فيها منشات بنا تحتيه مدنيه بما
فيها مطار دولي هي عمل ارهابي جديد
بعد تعليق دام ثلاث ساعات استانفت رحله
مطار ابن كوفو وهو احد المطارات الدوليه
الكبرى الثلاثه في موسكو الحرب الدائره
سببها اطراف خارجيه عملت منذ السنوات على
انشاء كيان معاد لروسيا على حدودها سبق
وان سمع هذا التبرير على لسان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين المناسبه هذه المره
مشاركته في قمه افتراضيه لمنظمه شنغهاي
الان في الواقع تشن حرب هجينه ضدنا
وتستخدم فيها العقوبات غير الشرعيه ضد
روسيا على نطاق غير مسبوق اود ان اؤكد ان
روسيا تقاوم وستقاوم بثقه الضغط الخارجي
والعقوبات والاستفزازات